uh yeah tick tock in the shorts
definitely haven't helped in hacking
your brain to be like okay on to the
next thing but consume consume consume
but then i talked to my dad and he like
can't remember the word for anything and
i'm like [ __ ] is that what i'm gonna be
like
i think that's a different
problem he's just like he just refuses
to learn like the if you if he's learnt
a word a certain way he just will never
correct it like what do you mean like it
like he's he um
like pronouncing or like yeah
pronunciation yeah he he will never
change the pronunciation once he's
decided what the pronunciation is in his
head i don't think that's a memory issue
i think that's just being stubborn but i
think that is like an older thing
because i think i've met a few older
people who do that whether you're like
you you correct the pronunciation like
no oh no my dad is like that as well my
dad's like he tells a fact and then i go
um actually it's not and then he's like
no no no
i'm not credible i'm kind of like that
yeah i know are you gonna tell me that
gif is not pronounced gif it is gif i i
don't give a [ __ ] if he says that's the
point i don't give a [ __ ] if that guy
says
yeah yeah i don't give a [ __ ] it's gift
it's gif and like [ __ ] the world
could end and like don't have a say even
though you made it yeah
the g stands for graphic you don't say
no it's exactly sound it's gif
like they could be like like there could
be a gun to my head to be like you can
live if you just say jeff and be like no
shoot me now
i'll i'll take the gun off him
i don't know you know even if you made
the thing i think you can have you know
if
if you made it a clear from the start
that it was that and that's what it was
but it became massive public domain
and was widely used before they became
into the public discourse that it was
called jiff right right so at that point
no he might have been saying it for a
while but he didn't do a very good job
of making everyone know it was jeff he
should everything at the bottom should
have watermark saying it is pronounced
gif yeah
to make it clear
but i feel like as a creator you don't
really have much uh say over how no no
especially when it becomes that
widespread yeah yeah it's already like
rooted into society there are so many
things that like once they're adopted by
the public you know you they become
their own kind of beast right it becomes
its own thing yeah and you don't really
get a sale for it well that's like if
you know arno came out tomorrow and said
it's actually pronounced evangelion so
i'll be like no it's not
it's it's
jk rowling telling us like weird harry
potter facts like like they just [ __ ]
they [ __ ] themselves and then teleport
it away
no i don't believe
even though you made this and this is
your world no no you don't have anything
pronounced harry pooter actually you
don't have a say over there what was the
other weird one that he brought out like
something weird about hagrid or
something
it was dumbledore's gaze dumbledore was
getting
ready yeah that was already canonical
there was another one with like hagrid
where it was like something really
[ __ ] weird about yeah i can't
remember and i was like
it was like
hagrid had a [ __ ] threesome with
snape and then
what are you doing jk rowling why why
are you doing this
it happens in between the first two
balls
interesting isn't it how like if you do
try and retcon things or what it feels
like retconning the audience will be
like no yeah i mean i mean yeah i mean
anno's done that several [ __ ] times
because he's he's come out several times
saying like no it's it's not like that
like for example the crosses the the
cross doesn't mean anything the cross
doesn't mean anything although i just
put this in because i thought it was
cool and yeah i guess so i guess it
comes and people are like no no no no
but then that's interesting right
because then that takes the argument of
it's not whether as much as it's not
really anything to do with the media
itself it's more so to do with what the
public likes you and like is like yeah
yeah it's whether or not the public
actually takes you seriously so like
even if she released a new book i'm sure
people will be like nah it's not
colonical i don't like her
well sometimes you sometimes you just
gotta decide you know and also i think i
think she has pushed it with what she
can get the audience to agree with yeah
yeah yeah i think once you've brought in
these characters and you've brought in
this world there's a certain amount of
uh no i don't i don't really agree with
that yeah like well i mean she certainly
hasn't helped her public image with that
kind of stuff right meanwhile if like
[ __ ] nasu came out with another fake
thing it was like uh yes this is
actually not canonical all the nuts fans
will be like yes thank you nasu thank
you for another piece
ever ridiculous with the stuff that he
suggested have you seen able
yeah but like it's all it's all always
in line you know
hearing ava is the definition of
ridiculous that's why it's in line harry
potter had rules to some extent yeah and
to hear her go yeah oh the reason why
hagrid doesn't have kids is because he
exclusively fists people that's not
that isn't something that he's incapable
of reproducing you know that doesn't
line up with
what i understood
[Music]
i mean it's not as any more ridiculous
than like taking a [ __ ] and making it
disappear
like like but i also love that i also
think that's amazing why wasn't that in
the movies like like i was like
sometimes sometimes like i think
sometimes as an author and as a consumer
you've got to understand you've got to
think sometimes at what point is there
too much detail in world yeah that's the
exact point when there's too much
[ __ ] speed
i just loved that
jk rowling thought about this after the
fact i thought that's a neat little fan
i will let everyone know
siri played to
this also makes me wonder was just like
were they just [ __ ] fascinated when
they first saw a toilet in like the
human world they're like holy [ __ ] you
have a room dedicated for [ __ ]
this is amazing
like you know do they wipe like
do they do they have does that get
teleported as well yeah there's like no
it doesn't get teleport i believe it
like did it get teleported or is it
every single but then by that sense
you'd never need a shower because every
single thing attached to your body
including some this is you know well
does it get teleported inside no i think
i think i think what i remember from the
tweet that she did i think you take a
[ __ ] and then they don't teleport it
anywhere they just make it invisible
i think
oh they magic away the evidence that's
magical and what about you what does
that mean
that's so many interpretations almost
magic away the evidence
i need a five-page thesis i don't know i
need like a 10-20 page thesis i did like
a six-hour video on that like the people
on your ass though still like it's not
clean you need a bidet or something or i
assume does the spell get rid of that if
so then why would you need to ever
shower because surely the spell can also
get rid of any bodily fluids or odor
that you might have also you know when
they not and if they're inside of
someone they don't want to get them
pregnant do they just like delete us
yeah
[Laughter]
genuinely do they come and they can just
be like can be gone
like and it's gone
like
oh my god
are they able to cast spells if the if
they okay okay i i believe right i'm on
board with i'm on board with the fact
that you can you can spell away your own
fluids right in your own body if you if
you get your fluids into someone else's
body can your spells still get them away
does that does it can you can you get
rid of fluids in other people's bodies i
just like to imagine like [ __ ]
i want to say that next time i'm not
it's like baby where's the condom pulls
out of wand feeds
jk can you please make that [ __ ]
cannon please that's information i want
to know about the harry potter universe
yeah i don't i don't care about the
disappearing [ __ ] i care about what they
do to replace condoms in the harry
potter wall oh god i'm not gonna be able
to get that image out of my mind
i was having a rant and i was just like
off in my own world
it's like pointing the world down
i got you babe
sorry what are we talking about i'm
talking about
do you want to repeat your rant yeah
if you nut in somebody else yeah can you
get rid of their fluids because it's
technically inside of them i i guess so
you pull a fetus to let us then you
this is a very disgusting uh
conversation about one that needs to be
done it's fascinating it's fascinating
thank you thank you jk
for letting our imagination run wild
yeah for for
asking the important questions and
answering the importance i still can't
get over the [ __ ] like what was it
deleting the evidence with magic or some
[ __ ] yeah yeah whose own words vanished
the evidence vanish the evidence with
magic that's what i'm going to say in
court next time when i commit a murder
uh your honor i vanished the evidence
with magic